mandela's leaving behind cold wintry
Germany our contest in espeically is in
Valencia testing the smart convertible
to get in the mood for summer she's
brought ahead along though just in case
there's a noise that's typical of the
smart and it doesn't come from the
engine but we'll get to that in a moment
today eNOS is testing the models more
powerful gasoline model which puts out
66 kilowatts and has a dual clutch
transmission at 0 to 100 km/h in just
under 12 seconds the smart isn't exactly
a rocket but it certainly claws back
some points on emissions just under 100
grams of co2 per kilometer
the convertibles bodywork is very
similar to the coop a version
but the b-pillars behind the seats are
slimmer in the open top model time to
get the roof down fold it all the way
back and remove the sidebars that's it
in sloppiness listens for the smarts
characteristic clack clack when you take
the bars out and put them back in
college he also points out the models
nifty storage solution for the bars they
can be neatly stowed away here in the
tailgate there's even a lid with a handy
locking strap to keep them secure
the folding Grove hardly impacts on the
trunk storage at all between 260 and 340
leaders still fit in here that's only
ten liters less than the coop a luggage
for a weekend trip for two would fit
nicely in assess there's a knack to
closing the trunk because of the extra
weight of the bars you need just the
right amount of force get up too much
momentum and it slams pretty hard but if
you're too meek it won't close and
you'll get a warning on the dashboard
telling you to go back and try again it
takes some getting used to the catalyst
dad I'm was malicious member single food
another of the Koopas virtues that's
been passed on to the convertible that
tiny turn radius just under seven meters
anyone can change directions like this
I've been pulling a swift u-turn within
the bounds of a street that's a job for
a smart but is this car a true
convertible though how breezy does it
get inside time for a hair check well
it's definitely hairy
yep that's windy gives you that real
convertible feeling and the hat came in
handy after all our test car has the
prime equipment onboard it's black
fittings are offset by elegant accent
stitching in gray the multimedia unit
sits in the center of the dashboard like
a computer tablet providing a modern
touch the driver can even display
content from a cell phone penis finds
the izzo fix connectors especially
practical they allow you to attach a
child or baby seat quickly and easily so
the car could also be a parent's best
friend you could switch between eco and
sport modes while driving and the
difference in the throttle response is
really noticeable even as it kupe the
smart is zippy and nimble around the
city but the convertible offers an added
bonus
it hasn't it eNOS never would have
thought to square meters of fabric could
make such a difference she warns that
this isn't a car for Speed junkies
though on the highway it can only hit
155 kilometers an hour and anything
above 120 is pretty noisy but what she
really likes is how easy it is to
retract the roof you don't need to
decide before you set off whether you
want to ride top up or top down that's
really great Meister that's the
foolishness clef ler now to the question
of money the surcharge for the soft top
comes in at three thousand seven hundred
euros so our test car with prime
fittings will set you back just over
eighteen thousand euros in Germany
that's a lot of money for a small city
car but if you're looking for an
open-air drive it's an investment that
really pays off
you